and i'm denise feldas that followed new
guidelines from the cdc that nevada is
following now statewide but
the news is getting some mixed reaction
sasha loftis live tonight with what you
need to know about wearing masks
sasha denise and brian many said they
are ready to ditch these masks
while others believe everyone should
wear them for a while longer
the expert i spoke with tonight says
this news
is really a sign we are getting closer
to the other side of the pandemic
it's news so many have been waiting to
hear
i got texts emails everyone is so
excited
but others are not quite ready for i
believe that
people should continue to wear their
masks the cdc announced thursday
those fully vaccinated against covid19
can now remove their masks
in most situations without wearing a
mask or physical distancing
so what does this mean for us here at
home i think this news
you know tells our population that
things are getting closer
to a normal state unlv medical school
dean dr mark j
khan calls these relaxed requirements a
sign we're learning more about the virus
and vaccine effectiveness the growing
body of
evidence suggests that fully vaccinated
people
aren't likely to transmit the virus but
if you haven't gotten your shots
it's important to keep that face
covering on he also calls
cleanliness crucial to ward off other
illnesses
as we relax mass requirements i think we
will see an increase in colds and things
so as we inch toward that post-pandemic
world i'm going to encourage those that
are not vaccinated to get vaccinated
many say they're ready to embrace
whatever comes
next moving in the right direction
now under state guidelines businesses
are not required to ask for this proof
of vaccination card but they are
allowed to do that if you are going to
again a private business
now they are also allowed to require
masks for the foreseeable future
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now